and about the poor driver Neil Armstrong
set foot on the moon in 1969 six hundred
million people tuned in to watch by 1972
enthusiasm did wane deliver but Apollo
16 carry is significant if little
celebrated first a telescope to view the
earth and heavens from the lunar surface
the chance to put a telescope on the
moon was a great opportunity for the
young astronomer George Carruthers with
this telescope he confirmed that gas
clouds between stars contain molecular
hydrogen as astronomers that expected
and took photos of the earth in UV light
displaying the extent of our hydrogen
atmosphere the Apollo program was wound
up later in 1972 and Carruthers
telescope has sat lonely on the
Descartes Highlands ever since but that
didn't keep scientists from dreaming and
scheming of using the moon as a base for
observing the universe now exploring and
exploiting the moon is back in fashion
and astronomers hope to seize this
opportunity to turn the moon into a
grand observatory the lonely telescope
may soon have some new friends radio
astronomers are particularly eager to
build a telescope there to peer back
into the deep dark past of the universe
for several hundred million years after
the Big Bang had cooled the universe was
dark and featureless filled with neutral
hydrogen gas but no stars within these
clouds very occasionally a hydrogen atom
would spontaneously emit a photon with a
unique frequency of 1.4 gigahertz that
light is referred to as the 21
centimeter line owing to its unique
wavelength
the Earth's ionosphere blocks these
faint signals from space and terrestrial
transmitters cause noisy interference
the lunar far side is the perfect place
to detect these low-frequency signals as
it's shielded from interference from
Earth and the moon has no ionosphere
with an array of widely spaced antennas
on the far side astronomers could map
the density of neutral hydrogen across
space and time during that dark age
identifying the clumps of gas that would
later form into galaxies teams of
astronomers are planning experiments to
see just how feasible this is starting
with moon orbiting satellites with
extending antennas designed to detect
this Dark Age signal another plan could
use autonomous Rovers to lay out
antennas made of conducting film in huge
arrays to reduce a lunar radio
Observatory the Rovers can be controlled
by crew onboard NASA's plan moon
orbiting space station although Radio
Astronomy has a compelling case for a
lunar Observatory optical and infrared
telescopes on the moon would also be
hugely valuable telescopes on earth can
be made very large to capture the faint
light of distant objects but they're
always at the mercy of shifting
fluctuations in the density of the
atmosphere the process that makes the
stars twinkle modern telescopes can
compensate for this effect to a degree
with deformable mirrors but telescopes
in space are immune to the problem this
is why the Hubble telescope is able to
peer further than any ground-based
instrument despite its relatively small
mirror the size of orbiting telescopes
like Hubble is limited by the capacity
of the rockets that launched them but if
a way could be made to make mirrors on
the moon it might be possible to build a
telescope with clearer vision than
Hubble
one approach that astronomers have been
studying would be to create a mirror
from a spinning liquid this process
seems straightforward take a large
circular dish fill it with the liquid
gently spin it and centripetal force
naturally creates the perfect parabolic
shape for a mirror on earth this has
been done with liquid mercury which is
naturally reflective but on the moon
mercury would evaporate instead
researchers believe that they could use
a molten salt that won't evaporate
topped with a thin layer of reflective
silver less than a hundred nanometers
thick in the moon's low gravity the
necessary support structure would be
simple and cheap to build and since the
moon is seismically quiet no tremors
would disturb the spinning liquid but
building a 20 metre telescope on the
moon 10 times the width of Hubble would
still require transporting over three
tons of materials from Earth which
doesn't come cheap one solution to that
problem is to use local materials one
team has made a small test mirror by
mixing simulated moon dust with epoxy
if such telescopes could be constructed
cheaply then it would be possible to
make arrays of telescopes and combine
their light to achieve a resolution
unimaginable on earth good enough to
study the surface of planets around
nearby stars
none of these plans have yet gotten the
green light but with private space
agencies and companies planning
expeditions in the near future
opportunities may soon arise but renewed
interest in the moon comes at a price if
companies begin activities such as
mining for minerals on the lunar surface
this pristine vantage point may be
oiled before astronomers even get a
chance to use it
you
[Music]